at her family home in county dunny goal
kerry frye is trying to prepare for a
new term at university in dublin but
after four months of searching is still
without a place to rent term starts in
about a week and a half and nowhere to
live nowhere to go no one will take
students with the term so close it's
just
very terrifying honestly
kerry has even seen fraudulent listings
trying to scam students out of deposits
amid this rent crisis irish police say
such crime has increased by 30 percent
since before the pandemic they probably
are desperate yet but they're also
seeing it as a one-time offer you know
it's been offered in deceit on social
media this is one chance you must take
it today there's a sense of urgency if i
don't take it i'm going to lose it
construction shut down during covet and
simply cannot meet demand private
landlords have left the market in droves
driven off by high tax and rent controls
it's led to scenes like this the queues
for a viewing of just one rental
property in the capital recently
from donegal to dublin the rental crisis
is touching every part of ireland
nationwide a new low was reached last
month when according to one leading
property website in a country of more
than 5 million people there were just
over 700 rental properties available
anywhere in ireland
after five years courtney doyle has
finally found a place to rent with help
from a government scheme it's urgently
needed as she's six months pregnant
it must mean worrying yeah at the time
that you fell apart
you had no home no i mean it caused a
lot of stress some anxiety you know
especially like celtic and i was like
what if i don't find a place on time is
it suitable to go ahead with a pregnancy
is it fair but there's just not enough
houses for us or they're just not
affordable you know especially for
people who have lower income
the government can't hide the scale of
the problem how chronic is ireland's
rental crisis
look it's accused there is no question
of that
we've had an issue of under supply
across all 10 years of housing for the
last 10 years
there's no question and that has made
the situation much more difficult the
government has launched a 4 billion euro
a year housing for all plan to try and
tackle the problem but for now all over
ireland the search for somewhere to rent
remains frustrating and fruitless
stephen murphy sky news